when Star Wars the last Jedi hits
theaters on December 15th it's
guaranteed to be one of the biggest
box-office hits of the year if not all
time so why are some theaters flat-out
refusing to screen the movie at all
according to a report by The Wall Street
Journal Disney is imposing harsh
financial requirements on the theaters
they'll partner with to screen the last
Jedi terms that many theater owners are
calling the most onerous that you've
ever seen
typically movie studios take 55 to 60%
of ticket sales for a first-run film
with that percentage dropping the longer
the movie is out however as one film
insider told The Wall Street Journal
Disney is currently in the most powerful
position any studio has ever been in
thanks to the fact of the last film in
the series 2015 star wars the force
awakens is by far the biggest domestic
box-office hit in history as a result
Disney is asking for an unprecedented
65% of the box-office take from all
participating theaters needless to say
the studio has significantly altered the
usual deal I have altered the deal pray
I don't alter it any further
this deals getting worse all the time
but wait the deal does get worse any
theater that wants to show the last Jedi
also has to agree to screen it for a
full four weeks at a minimum in their
biggest auditorium Plus Disney is also
imposing an uncommon penalty for
violating these terms to Disney deem any
theater to be in violation of the
agreement the agreement says that Disney
is then allowed to take an additional
five percent of ticket sales from the
theater meaning that for four weeks
seventy percent of all money earned for
the last Jedi in a theater would go
straight to Disney violations according
to Disney would include pulling even one
screening from a theater scheduled or
using marketing materials for the movie
before Disney gives the go-ahead while
these terms still are harsh for massive
chains like AMC or Cinemark the
conditions really hurt smaller theaters
serving small populations and some
independent theater operators are
considering fighting back by boycotting
the last Jedi entirely one cinema owner
who operates a single screen theater
noted that in his small town everyone
who wanted to see the last Jedi would
see it in the first two weeks leaving
the owner stuck playing the movie for
the last two weeks to what would
eventually be an empty room for this
trouble the theater would keep only 35
percent of the increasingly meager
profits from it all or 30 percent of
Disney decides they broke a rule can
during the record-breaking success of
the force awakens it's easy to see why
Disney would want more money but as
crazy as it sounds might actually make
more financial sense for some theaters
not to screen the last Jedi at all
rather than give in to Disney's demands
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]